it splits between the Ukrainian and
Russian Orthodox churches could soon
become official my colleague Neil Harvey
discussed the situation with our
correspondent Daniel Hawkins
well religious scandals around churches
in Ukraine too many might seem
irrelevant a historic theological debate
but actually it carries a lot more
meaning to Orthodox believers we need to
look at the basic first the Eastern
Orthodox Church is made up of 15
different churches each of which one has
autonomy in religious language that is
called autocephaly meaning the church
has its own self-governance independence
and jurisdiction now the russian
orthodox church for centuries has had
rule over the key of orthodox church
that's been the case since about the
17th century it's the only officially
recognized congregation or water Doxey
in ukraine on the other hand though
there have been political and religious
factions in the country which a very
long time pushed for a independent
Ukrainian Orthodox Church to be
established indeed the president of
Ukraine Petro poroshenko has been a
supporter of this
he's implied that the creation of this
church is just as important to Hugh
cranes independence and rebirth as
joining the EU or NATO autocephaly is
the most important event from the same
series as our aspiration to join the EU
and NATO the association agreement a
visa-free regime with the EU withdrawal
from the CIS rejection of the deceptive
treaty on friendship with Russia etc all
this is the basis of our own way of
development development of Ukraine so if
this is going to happen it's not going
to come easily it's quite a complicated
situation in Ukraine isn't it yes
there's more than one Orthodox Church in
Ukraine apart from the main one
recognized officially as part of the
Moscow Patriarchate there are also two
other churches now they broke away in
the early 90s when Ukraine got its
independence from the USSR this is the
Kiev page rocket and the Ukrainian
autocephalous church these claimed
independence but they've never been
recognized officially as official
congregations that's until very recently
when the patriarch of Constantinople
made moves to give them that autonomy
that independence as well this is very
much angered the Moscow patriarchy
the process of granting autocephaly is
artificial imposed from outside does not
reflect internal ecclesiastical
necessity will not bring real church
unity will deepen division and intensify
conflicts among the people of Ukraine
under these conditions the participation
of the episcopate clergy and laity of
the UO see in these processes is
considered impossible and how is the
Russian Orthodox Church reacted well
this has triggered a total breakdown in
relations the Moscow Patriarchate has
rejected this decision they've stated
that they have had authority over the
Kiev congregation since the 17th century
and they've even called the schism
triggered a schism with constantinople
banning their followers from attending
any ceremonies any communions with this
church who they have now officially
split with the russian orthodox church
does not accept these decisions and will
not follow them schism is schism and its
leaders are the leaders of the schism
and the church that accepted the schism
excluded itself from the canonical field
a decision has been made to rupture full
communion with the constantinople
Patriarchate's we cannot be in
communication with this church which is
in schism what about the everyday
churchgoers will they in any way be
affected well I think it's going to
cause a lot of confusion and division I
mean this is seen as a wider context as
part of that conflict between Russia and
Ukraine east and west those debates over
independence and cultural heritage one
priest Father Mike Tyson who's worked in
West Virginia for 15 years has even
switched churches in the wake of this
schism he was he's left his patriarchate
of constantinople parish switching to
russian church he says this is
supporting being in solidarity with the
Ukrainian Orthodox Church and now in the
bigger picture here tensions have been
rising since about 2014 there have been
dozens of attacks since then by
Ukrainian nationalists an Orthodox
Church is aligned with Moscow they
viewed them as enemies of Ukraine as
effective tools of the Kremlin in terms
of church property there may be
conflicts as well the Moscow Alliance
Church owns around 12,000 parishes in
Ukraine those two are the Ukrainian
churches which may soon unite control
about half that number so in terms of
ownership of churches in terms of
revenue in terms of where followers are
going to go and practice their faith
this is certainly an issue that's not
going to go away and is likely to
certainly cause some more confusion and
division in a country already deeply
divided church history professor
Alexander de volcán says Ukraine's moves
will only make the country's divisions
worse operator worth all of you will
never allow Kiev Potrero gate to exist
whatever this new church will be that
will not give a tear Kate and I still
have my doubts that it will be fully
fully independent julio de cephalus very
soon there will be the discrimination of
those believers that would want to stay
but the canonical church will increase
then of course they will try to take our
property away from them I mean the
church property and it will increase
also there all the tensions in the
society it will weigh - it will increase
all the divisions in the society it will
increase or all the disagreements in the
society and it will hardly pain
you